i want to bring this back to what we
started with at the top of the show this
q
thing q anon which is what uh the all
that's all the democrats in the media
want to talk about
i think most conservatives don't even
know what this is they haven't even
heard of this
this is an internet meme right but the
press they're writing about it all the
time like this is the end of the world
so what is what is the cue thing i like
president trump also don't really know
much about it
but unlike democrats i do think we
should take
the fact that this movement exists
seriously
i don't i don't think we need to worry
about anything i don't think it's the
end of the world but
the fact that there is such an internet
meme that's become
you know something of an activist
movement what does it mean
you know i take blm seriously i don't
take blm's claims
seriously but i take blm seriously and i
wonder why did this rise up so same
thing with q
the the reporter brought up three things
religion weird sex and cannibalism
right satan satanism and then
pedophilia and then cannibalism what
does that mean well
as i mentioned earlier at the was it the
2012
dnc you had
the democrats booing god you now have
blm
top leftist activists calling for
churches to be smashed
uh images of christ and the virgin mary
to be smashed
you have statues of saint junipero sarah
being torn down it seems pretty clear
that there is a religious battle going
on as henry edward cardinal manning said
at bottom all human conflict ultimately
is theological
so you've got this religious battle
brewing i mean the people leading the
blm riots right the founders of that
organization
are marxists they're atheists again
in you you see this constant sort of
attack on religious americans the bitter
clingers clinging to their bibles
that image that that irritated the left
so much was trump holding up a bible
outside a church a church that they were
trying to burn down
so there's there is clearly a religious
issue going on how about the weird sex
there's plenty of weird sex going on
obviously there's the jeffrey epstein
thing that seems to involve every
prominent leftist in america
but even you know there's a show now on
netflix
it's called cuties my wife showed me
this last night she showed me the
trailer for it it's called
it's about 11 year old like go go
dancers or something
this listen to this description this is
just a from the netflix website cuties
amy
age 11 becomes fascinated with a
twerking dance crew
hoping to join them she starts to
explore her femininity
defying her family's traditions
is like pedophile catnip how on earth
what sicko executive at netflix
allowed this thing to go up like i i
know you know sometimes
we hear all these crazy people on the
internet they talk about how there's
pedophilia going on all over the place
well what do you how do you explain that
that's pretty weird isn't it there's
like a show about 11 year olds twerking
and exploring their femininity against
their family's wishes
that's that's weird like you know
jeffrey epstein flying around on an
airplane with
prince andrew and all these top mostly
left-wing politicians like he was a
member of mar-a-lago so there were
photos of him with trump too
but bill clinton apparently flew on his
plane like 27 times
that's weird isn't that weird that's a
little weird isn't it so clearly there's
some weird sex thing going on and by the
way the only thing anyone talks about
these days is sex that's why lgbtq can
you know
goes now 26 alphabet letters long
these people beyond this question of
pedophilia people are just obsessed with
sex they're talking about sex
all the time so there's there's that
aspect going on and then cannibalism
there are some real cannibals like reza
aslan formerly of cnn
who ate human brains on television
actually did that and that weird that's
a little weird too
uh but there's this issue of cannibalism
at a cultural level which
which i think is actually what's going
on here we are eating ourselves alive
we are we are devouring our own culture
right cannibalism has a has a kind of
metaphorical meaning as well
people are just devouring themselves
because they've they've run out of other
things to consume
what is i mean obviously we see that now
we're tearing down our own history we're
tearing down our own art we're covering
up our own art
where we're destroying our own politics
destroying our own institutions
frankly riza aslan aside there's much
more evidence of a cultural cannibalism
a civilizational cannibalism
than of a personal cannibalism those
things are all real
okay and the media right now are asking
about the q anon
thing they're asking about a bunch of
internet memes they should be asking
themselves
about what the phenomenon means the fact
that people are
worried about satanism and pedophilia
and
cannibalism why what does that tell you
about your culture
if these mainstream media journalists
had two brain cells to rub together
they would be able to see some some real
insight in
in the very fact of these phenomenons
just like i encouraged the left
consider the fact of blm why has this
thing risen up
so too i would encourage the left
consider why
these things that you you're so obsessed
with consider
why they've risen up but that would
require introspection and of course
they're not capable of that i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts